You know,
another thing that struck me about your
book that was quite interesting I
thought was that you list the names of a
very large number of totally unsung
heroes,
you know,
those are people and we have a very
interesting table near the beginning
where you list,
I think about 10 names,
maybe 12 of people who've saved between
hundreds of billions and billions of
lives with their scientific,
with their incremental scientific
productivity.
And yet those are people that are by no
means household names.
That's another place where things don't
make the news.
Yes,
absolutely.
And it's a,
it's funny how our
moral,
a crediting our moral,
our awarding of World Brownie points
doesn't quite correlate with how much
good people often doesn't at all
correlate.
And the case of the inventors of
synthetic fertilizer,
of vaccines,
of chlorination,
of public water,
supplies of the green revolution in
agriculture are,
are pretty much unknown.
And they literally say billions of lives
a.
whereas various reformers and,
and,
uh,
profits and agitators are a pretty well
known.
A number of,
uh,
certainly people who are painted by the
Roman Catholic Church who have to
perform a miracle that might resolve
resulted saving one life,
of course in fact did not because
miracles don't happen,
but the fact that that definition of
saint has nothing to do with saving
lives on scales of millions or billions
to shows like human moral sense is not
really well calibrated to morality as we
would have defended myself.
I think it was stolen who said something
like a single death is a tragedy,
but a million deaths is a statistic.
Maybe didn't say it,
but,
uh,
but it's,
it's a conventionally attributed to him.
So let's say for good reason.
I mean,
I suppose I could have said it to or I
guess maybe the same thing plays in
reverse say,
is that the saving of a single life has
a narrative punch and the incremental
savings of 100 million lives,
especially through prevention.
That's another problem,
right?
Because prevention isn't dramatic
because the terrible thing merely
doesn't happen.
And that's,
um,
I,
I rather cheekily wrote an article on
the human moral sense that began with a,
who do you,
who do you think is most a morally
Praiseworthy Mother Teresa or Bill Gates
or Norman Borlaug.
And this was before a gates is pivot
from a computer technology to
philanthropy was,
was well known.
It was about 10 years ago.
And I set it up as a bit of a trick
question because of course everyone
would say mother Teresa,
even in our field and in discussions
with moral psychology,
whenever a speaker has to pull out of
the air and example of a particularly
moral person,
Mother Teresa is the stereotype.
Even though if you ask people,
well,
what did she accomplish?
Uh,
how many lives did she save?
How many sick people did she actually
cure?
A,
it's very hard to come up with,
for actual accomplishment.
What does Bill Gates has already been
credited with saving perhaps $100
million lives through his efforts to
eliminate affection,
infectious disease living world.
And Norman Borlaug won the Nobel Peace
Prize in 1970 for his role in a
fermenting.
The green revolution probably saved a
billion lives,
selective breeding of hybrid crops that
required less fertilizer that could be
grown twice a year,
less water,
higher yields,
less susceptibility to disease,
which countries like Mexico and India
from a from basket cases to exporters of
food in,
in,
in less than a decade.
Right.
Do you think that would be a story that
everyone in in elementary and junior
high school would learn because it's
such a remarkable.
It's an absolutely remarkable story and
no one.
I mean,
I don't know what percentage of people
would know his name,
his name,
but I don't imagine it's.
It's.
I suspect it's in the low percentages if
that.
I,
I'm sure that's right.
I think there may have been a change.
I seem to recall a,
although I hate to begin any sentence
with when I was young a day,
but we,
we did read heroic biographies of
Medical Pioneers like annotating the
discover of sewage and that Thomas
Edison,
and I don't know if that kind of a
heroic biography of the innovator of the
inventor a scientist is as common at
children's education.
Yeah,
I suspect,
I strongly suspect not.
It certainly wouldn't be in Canada given
the tilt that our education system has
taken.